[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st
louis chess club hello everyone i'm
grand master dennis
borosch and we're back again with
another
special interview where you get to meet
special personalities and broadcasters
on twitch youtube and in the world so
today my special guest is a broadcasting
legend
and a gold medalist from the turin
olympiad
fiona thank you for joining us
thank you so much for having me it's a
pleasure
so i'm very pleased to have you
especially because
the event that you broadcast and you
gave uh like interviews
and interview people was with the
legends themselves
yes i panko and this new crop of
prodigies can you talk
talk a little bit more about that yeah i
mean so the
the recently uh tata steel chess
tournament which just concluded
a week ago in the netherlands one of the
very few
over the board tournaments which are are
able to go ahead
uh at the moment so it was uh
particularly nice
to be there i mean we were such a small
team there was
nobody there usually it's a festival for
thousands of people but this year which
was literally just the players
and the seconds and the staff that was
it um
and the interviews so as you mentioned i
did have the first week of the
tournaments i did the
the commentary with daniel naredicki who
i'm sure many of you
will know and then the second week i was
doing the interviews
and yeah i think you mentioned already
essie panko i think one of the heroes
of the tournament he beat his own hero
magnus carlsen
and i think it's got to be probably one
of the most
emotional interviews i i ever did
because
talking to him right after he beat
magnus was so i almost got emotional
just thinking of it now because he was
so
happy you know and the joy was so pure
it was something i had never really seen
in a player before and it was clear you
know
when i uh had interviewed him earlier in
the tournament he was saying you know
magnus is my my hero and it will be my
first game against him
and yeah i mean to beat him was just
very special i think
so you've got to be in all of these big
events
so i'm pretty sure if i remember
correctly you were also there when
rapport beat magnus
when what rapper it could have been a
couple of years ago
and why can't i can say yes i must
have been there you're putting me on the
spot so i guess i mean i was there
two years ago it's just so funny because
now we have so much material and so many
different reactions some are said yeah i
beat the world champion
and i was like yay this is the first
time i beat the world champion
i know i mean it's so it's so so rare
obviously i was um i'd actually i have
to admit forgotten the report game but
now you mentioned it i'm like yeah
i was definitely there for that but um i
was also there in
in norway a couple of months ago and
magnus lost his streak obviously when he
um
when he lost to to duda so those are the
the special moments i remember but yeah
can you recall
you're refreshing my my memory can you
recall
duda's reaction oh dude i was actually
dude i was
quite composed of course he was happy
but i think he's so
he's so humble you know he's quite i
wouldn't necessarily have to stay shy
but i think uh
it always takes a moment to to sink in
you know i think beating magnus is
something so special
for everyone you know the guy doesn't
lose
he doesn't lose so many losing is not
his specialty
no that really isn't so i think it was
very different you know the the reaction
from duda was very
obviously he was happy but very composed
well i think yes
panko just couldn't hide you know the
emotions were just
pouring out and the best part so
if you guys don't know fiona she does
these blogs
and secret behind-the-scene footages
so i have to ask behind the scene before
the last round
of tata steel did jordan party
that no no partying there was my
goodness
dennis i'm sorry to disappoint you but
there was literally
zero partying i mean on the last night
on
last night after the tournament was over
a few drinks
might be have might be had in uh
in hotel rooms but the thing is in the
netherlands everything is closed
um restaurants are closed bars are
closed
and uh yes even the beaches are closed
even though who would go out there it's
so cold each and every
like every time it's super cold there i
heard yeah exactly the beaches are open
but uh yeah the they're freezing also
the
there was a curfew was introduced
halfway through the tournament so nobody
could leave the hotel
after 9 p.m so vik is usually
it is known to have had a party or two
but not not this year this year was a
very different
a very different tournament it was
actually very strange in some ways
usually you get a very tense tiebreaker
but the players were chatting with each
other
yeah i mean so for those who don't know
your then
van ferece the winner of the tournament
he played a tie break against danish
giri the
the two dutchmen so it was a special
moment for the dutch
no dutch player had won the tournament
since 1985 so it was a long time
a long time coming for the the dutch
fans and of course for them to get you
know
two of their players into the the
playoff
and be guaranteed a dutch winner
was really special and yeah i remember i
so i was there in the the backstage area
before
sort of before the playoff began and
there was a bit of waiting around of
course there was the the controversy
with alireza so that was not ideal but
because of that there was a bit of
rating around
uh and yeah the players it was funny
they were both there with their
respective second
so anish had uh airvin lami with him and
jordan had max farmadam so both of them
had
had dutch dutch seconds as well and so
the four of them were just like
chatting and joking and so that was that
was nice
to see and even between the games they
were chatting to each other and joking
yeah that was special yeah it was
special
but then yeah not expecting unexpected
final or an unexpected winner for sure
honestly i have to say that
just from the pure excitement the games
that jordan has brought to the table was
outstanding
like i could watch
any other game but okay this seems like
a berlin i think i've seen this before
okay this is a little bit more
aggressive italian
only the 50th italian this tournament
and then there's a game by jordan
where everything's crazy never seen the
position before
and he just smashes his opponent
yeah i mean it was incredible i think
you would not expect
a player who goes into the tournament as
what 10 for 11
seed out of 14 and
you know he's never won of course he had
successes the guy was close to 2700
going into the tournament but
on this stage you have magnus carlsen
you have fabiano carrana
and playing this kind of chess i think
it was uh
yeah simply a stunning performance and
such exciting games to to follow and
i thought it was really nice how jordan
in his final interview really gave a big
shout out
to his second and friend maxwell madame
who you know
uh worked so hard behind the scenes and
it's something that danya and i talked
about quite a bit as well during our
commentary i think how important it is
when you play these huge tournaments to
not just have a second who will
prepare the lines for you but also
someone um
who gives you uh you know company and a
bit of a social push
like just enjoying yourself in the tough
times
exactly exactly and um especially in
these
in these times you know where there is
no there is no
socializing um like there's a lot of
players during the tournament that i
never saw outside
outside the playing hall i think
everyone was literally just
in their rooms in the playing hall
getting some take away food and uh
and that was that by the way uh their
twitch chat and youtube
if you feel like asking a question for
fiona she is
up for any questions bring your hardest
ones
please you know what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna because
i think my mom is watching so hi mom
hello
and she told me she told me that i am
not hosting you which i don't know how
that is possible because i
i rated earlier but so let me
let me correct my mistake
and uh and that's done now oh nice
so that kind of reminds me um it's so
nice that
now the seconds get their shoutouts
before they were like all hidden
they would literally would be literally
put into closets so they can get out
or locked into their rooms so they won't
be
known so times are changing
i know i mean it's really like i
remember the days when we had to wait
years to find out you know who were the
teams of the players and then we'd hear
like yeah so
two years ago for my match those were
those were my seconds but yeah it's
great these days too
to give them more more credit because
they deserve all the credit i mean they
work
so such crazy hours they are in the
shadows so
it's good to see them get their shout
outs
yeah and um the other thing that
actually made me cry inside
because of course it's a great story to
have jordan fun forest win
and have an all dutch final but imagine
if yes panko would have won the event as
one of the lowest seed
wild wildcarded that probably would have
been history on the spot i don't even
think in tata steel or v kansei
there ever was a wild card player who
wasn't originally invited
winning the whole event yeah i
i really can't think of anyone and
i thought he had such a great chance
because with three rounds to go i
remember after the final rest day there
were three games to go
and just looking at the the schedule of
the players or their
remaining opponents on paper sipenko
seemed to have the best chances but then
he lost to ari antari
in round 11 or 12
and in hindsight i mean if he had won
that game
he would have been the sole leader but i
mean it's also i think he
that's just experience for you um
i think he he will come back stronger i
think still you know
of course it would have been great for
him to win it but to finish
third is also also incredible and he's
so young i mean he's 18.
i'm sure he has a very very bright
future ahead of him
so talking about these young kids what
are the
relationship between each other because
you usually get okay
ferruja won this game tary won this game
they beat each other
yesipeko makes this big result against
carlson jordan from forest winds
but what did you see are they cordial
with each other or they're like
looking from a distance really cold can
you
build some secrets here well i don't
think it's secrets i think
the chess world in a way is not so
different from other words where it's
just like okay you have
certain friends and i think what i saw
mostly is that
the generations like i think for example
jordan is good friends with arientari
and also alexander linchenko is that
kind of same age so you would see
these guys hang out
i think maxine is quite good friends
with magnus although i didn't see
and to be honest i never saw either
magnus or maxime
outside the playing hall anywhere um
and then you have two players i think
fabiano spends
just most of the time whenever i would
see him he was with wisdom because i'm
done up another very famous
and second they're inseparable they're
clearly inseparable
absolutely but i think it's a it's nice
like
i haven't observed so much as you do at
other tournaments where there's more
social occasions
but i haven't seen any kind of rivalry
or any
or any bad blood which i think is uh is
the main
the main thing talking about bad blood
and
some other sports chad is asking what do
you think about
liverpool's season it's not great
it's not going great uh last year so
i've been a liverpool friend for
for a long time and last season they
finally won the league for the first
time since i was born
and this year it started it started so
well but now
let's let's not talk about it
okay so we're going to gloss over this
one
and move on to your beginnings
so you started chess in luxembourg how
did it like did you have any chess lives
there or what how can we imagine the
chess live in luxembourg
um well like so many other people i
i started playing with my dad at home um
and then yeah i mean luxembourg i think
a lot of people don't realize it because
it's
such a small country you know they think
okay who could she possibly have played
with there's like 10 people living in
lochte
not quite i mean no we do actually have
a
chess scene and i i started playing i
was very lucky
luxembourg didn't have many girl players
and
i think i i was very lucky that my dad
was such a great coach you know i think
he did
um a fantastic job teaching me the
basics you know
so when i when i went to play my first
tournament i knew how to checkmate with
a queen and i know i knew how to
checkmate
with the rook and true rooks and all
this
all this basic kind of knowledge
and yeah so when i got to to play my
first tournament
so i was very quickly i joined the
national team when i was
11. and from there i basically
um all my friends
even up to this date all my
my closest friends all friends that i
made back then
in the chess world so it was um i always
look back on my
my early chess days very fondly you know
traveling to all this european youth and
world youth
with people who up to this day as uh my
best friend so it was uh
it was a lot of fun growing up and
playing chess and
having so many friends around so as it's
very close to that time period
you must have witnessed the rise of
shakhma medjarov
can you explain that because for some
they
remember magnus carlsen but for us
we remember shock moment yarrow i mean
shaq i remember him very well actually
so he has two
two sisters and elder sister zainab and
the younger sister turkan
and turkan was actually in my age group
so she's also born in
in 89 and i remember my first
either the first or second world youth
in 2000 or 2001 in ocho pisa which i'm
sure you've played there
yeah and so she was in my age group and
somehow we became
we became friends but i didn't speak
english at the time
and nor did she but we were you know
when you're children you just
communicate with sign language and
and so her and i became uh became
friends and
that's how i got to know shaq and
funnily enough we were just talking
about fight and day but so
i stayed friends with with the whole
family and i remember in 2005 i went to
vikanze for the first time just as a
chess fan because they were playing
there
just to see them but yeah i remember
i think as you say our generation when
we grew up shaq was just
he was such a beast like he was so good
and especially at blitz and he is so i
think the
the beautiful thing about shah is he's
so passionate
about chess like all these tournaments
you know he would always crush
every day he would beat some guy who
would sit down and every night he would
see him
play blitz somewhere against anyone
you know and yeah so shaq probably one
of the most
impressive players that i i got to
witness growing up and he was such a
nice guy he's been a great friend
since and i hope we'll see more of him
still i think he still has a push
a push in him i think so but i actually
remember
vividly he had a chance to qualify
in one of the candidates and it kind of
broke him a little bit emotionally
i saw him kind of get really emotional
when he didn't manage to qualify
i think um i think he might have been
in contention with kramnik and karana
yes
was it berlin yes i think it was
just uh i'm not
quite 100 sure that time but he had a
real shot at uh qualifying for the world
championships
uh 2016 where was yeah maybe your right
was 20. i think it's berlin
i think it's berlin with uh famous
grisham scenes i don't want to mention
but for that all of you can find uh
grisha compilations
it's live yeah
but uh just another side note with
mamedyarov so
how do you know if someone is going to
be a super ground master
well you look at the junior
championships
look at the result of medyarov back to
back junior championship
i was gonna say i think not only back to
back i think to this day he's the only
player to have won the world junior
championship twice no
yeah and uh he scored like 10 out of 11.
um twice mind boggling
like you don't see those scores at all
yeah
um but it's difficult because there's so
many talents yeah go ahead
but i think it's great that he you know
he adapted his style a little bit like
he was so
uncompromising but then i think he
continues with that style but he
brought some kind of uh
like being a bit more reasonable
sometimes into it and
it just made him i mean for people who
don't realize he was
as high up as number two in the world a
couple of years ago
i feel that both him and rajabo sort of
mellowed their chests and it kind of
brought them up so i think
like rajabov is clearly on the surge and
uh
of course i think he still plays the
king's indian time to time
but he is a little bit mellowed with his
openings just like shaka is
yeah well also we um we don't get that
we don't get younger both of them uh
also i i'm curious to see what's gonna
happen is the young guard just going to
take over
or do these guys because both of them
are family
and men now they are married they have
children
and uh for me it's always interesting to
see
you know when are the players in their
prime i mean magnus has been struggling
struggling for a little bit now i don't
think it's anything to do
with his age i think it's literally just
it happens like you can't just be
a complete beast all the time you know i
think these lulls just
it just happens but i'll be curious to
see
what the scene looks like i mean even
that law that
uh cousin has is the law that i'd like
to take each and every day
because he scores 95 percent all the
time in his tournaments
and he had one bad tournament and uh
yeah
that's not a bad statistic no absolutely
absolutely not and the other thing that
i wanted to mention there that i think
there's a misunderstanding there
is sort of a hype towards teenagers
which is a good thing and it's
completely understandable but i checked
some
peer-reviewed articles recently and they
say
you actually get best at your chess
between 30 and 32 33
so magnus is not even there yeah
yeah which is surprising actually but i
think it probably makes sense like
um because in chess you don't quite need
the physical strength that you need in
other sports and i think just you know
i think you're still fit like i mean
your early 30s even late
30s you can still be in absolute great
shape and you have all that
experience under your belt so i think it
when you think about it at first i was
surprised when but when you think about
it i think it makes sense
i mean it's just a different world now
and talking about the different world
you started becoming a twitch streamer
way before the
big boom what was the world like i i
assumed there you had john bartholomew
already there chess bros
simon williams um and that's
that's about all i can remember i mean
yeah so i started in the end of
2016 um
four and a half four and a half years
ago almost at this stage and it was
i can barely remember because when i
look at it now it's just
so incredible how much it has changed
because when i started actually what
pushed me to start is
i wanted to do a fundraiser and i
thought oh maybe a stream would be a
good way to
to do this and then after the fundraiser
was over i didn't stream again for
another
half year and then i had my ups and
downs now i've been streaming quite
regularly but yeah just
looking back especially
even i think even if you look back just
just a year and a half
or even just the year you know before
the the pandemic
really hit um
it was so different like i think people
who are new to the twitch scene
might not realize you know how few
people they were and how
niche how niche the chess streams
how niche uh how niche you seen it was
that but it's it's been great i mean i'm
i'm not complaining it's been so
fantastic to
to see all the way that uh
that chess has come and it's showing no
signs of uh
slowing down anytime soon yeah and
actually that kind of reminds me i just
looked up
uh your career and i just realized you
have
a team called smashing ponds now i
wouldn't
ever know that because sadly i don't
speak german
nor french so like all these puns where
do these puns come from
the smashing ponds is actually um it's
my my club in luxembourg
so it's a club that i i found that as i
mentioned earlier you know my best
friends i've known them for
for over 20 years and then yeah at some
point in 2020
in 2010 we decided let's just
uh create our own club
and we were brainstorming names and then
someone suggested smashing ponds and
you're like yeah
that's the winner
and yeah we're still going uh and
i see nice here in the chat smashing
pumpkins of course
was there was the inspiration um behind
it
and yeah that's uh the team still exists
i'm not
as active anymore because i'm not home
so often
um and unlike in most countries
in luxembourg as well league play has
been put on ice for the last
year but i still play for them whenever
i get the chance
that's great and there's one other
question here if you're talking smashing
pumpkins here
let's talk a little bit about the music
what chess players listen to i remember
a horrible time that is my personal take
where everyone in the top was listening
to
german rap music everybody
did that change
i actually that's a it's a very good
question and it's something that i think
that i should ask people more in my
my interviews because i actually can't
tell you
what players look uh listen to i know
that
rap i think is still quite popular
with a fair few people but i think these
days you get to write a better idea
because so many of the top guys stream
and so many of them listen
to music and i think sometimes i listen
in and i'm like
i wasn't expecting that kind of music
but i think that's another great thing
you know about um
about twitch and maybe one of the nicest
things is that
i think if you go back even as recently
as
five years in time but the more you go
back the the bigger the different
uh becomes is i think back then the top
players were these
obscure figures that you didn't really
know much about like you knew their
games and okay they would give
interviews
but you wouldn't really get to see
behind them
behind the curt like who really is never
see
yeah and these days i mean almost
every one of the players at the top will
stream or will play some banter blitz so
we'll do something and
i think it's so great that the fans get
to
and get to to see the players i see a
question in the in the youtube chat is
she really reading the chat
actually i have this two monitor setup i
have the youtube channel here
i have to twitch that there so yeah
keeping a very close eye
close tabs on everything
it's a i don't know if it's an
expression in english but in
in french they have a saying in a
different profession
it's like a professional
i don't even i don't know how to
translate it but it's something like a
habit that you
you pick up at work and so i mean i am a
streamer i am
also when i'm commentating i always a
natural multitasker that is
exactly keep everything you know
keep an eye on everything and there is
kind of a
well it's more of a statement from
xavier but
i do want to ask that you were one of
the first commentators
out there uh broadcasting on your own
doing commentary for these
smaller and bigger events honestly
that's the first time i met you
seeing you doing comment i think for
reykjavik if
if i remember correctly but actually
reykjavik was my my commentary debut
really yeah like i thought that oh
oh i like it felt so natural when you
were just maybe not the year i don't
know if it was the year we
we met so my and because
i've been to reykjavik so many times
that all the years are
melting into one but my debut was in
2014.
yeah so how did that start for you did
you want to do commentary
i mean i for some reason when i think
commentary or at least the big
beginnings
it was you it was fiona and anna rudolf
doing these commentary gigs absolutely
i think we were really two two of the
the first but it's great i think it's so
good that we we see
more and more women in chess um these
days and
of course the queen's gambit has helped
with that but uh for sure it's
uh it's good to see more girls getting
into jazz either playing or you know
commentating all that
but yeah how i got into commentating for
the first
uh time was actually really funny so i
had um
i had played so much chess for for quite
a few years i was averaging
averaging over 100 classical games per
year
while still being at uni so i was
basically just playing too much
uh chess and studying two little chess
and there came a point where i was just
fed up
with playing and i had reykjavik
lined up to play and the organizers
there have been
great friends for a long time so i used
to get some conditions to play i used to
i think i got like a hotel room or
something like that
um and of course i wanted to go to
reykjavik but i thought i really don't
want to play also reykjavik it's the
best tournament in the world but i lost
the rating
every time i played there yeah too much
fun
uh so i thought i really don't want to
really don't want to play so i asked the
organizers can i still come
but rather than playing i will help you
with
coverage so i didn't want to do i didn't
want to do commentary i said i can do
photos i can do social media i can write
some reports
and they were like sure that's fine and
i remember i got there and they said
actually is it
we thought you could do some commentary
and i was like what
i'd never done commentary in my life
but i thought sure and
so yeah i was commentating with zibit
ingrahamson
and yeah basically from from there on
out
uh just one opportunity
came arising after the other and then i
finished uni
in 2015 and then that was that
suddenly i was a chess i don't even know
sometimes you know when people ask me
what is it you do i wouldn't say i'm a
chess commentator
per se but it's hard to to define what
exactly
it is i do that kind of reminds me of
the question that okay
um i've seen you anna seen anna and you
do commentary but have you guys ever
done commentary together
we did very briefly
in 2016 we were both working for chess
24
[Music]
and i was commentating on the candidates
tournament in 2016
2016 uh the candidates tournament i was
commentating
in german with delia zaragatsky and anna
was commentating
in english with pepe crank actually here
in in hamburg i'm
back in hamburg again um and one time
pepe took
a break and we did some like 15 minutes
together on the candidates tournament
in 2014 but that's all unfortunately
uh that was all but i would love to i
would love to do more commentary with
her anna has been a great friend for
many years we actually
not only were we sort of the first to
to work in that environment but we were
also teammates
in the french league 10 years ago so
first we were playing on the same team
we went to a number of european club
cups together we were roomies
and yeah it's just been great and i mean
she's done so fantastically
well and it's just it's great to see her
growing and growing
yeah the only thing i remember vividly
is that you guys started
doing these commentary gigs but i don't
even know who was the first
boy male who sort of started doing
commentary as well
maybe it was actually simon well i think
the thing is i guess you have to
distinguish probably between
online because i know that for example
people like daniel king
oh yeah daniel was already commentating
in 93 at the
caspar of shirt uh matching more
essentially two i think
maurice also for a long time um
but yeah after that i don't i don't even
to be honest like i sometimes find it
hard looking back in time
if you ask me you know before you were
doing pre-2014
when you were watching tournaments who
were the the commentators on actually
struggling
yeah it was so rare actually yeah it was
so rare um
after that saint louis came along and so
many people put
more attention to having a live stream
but i think
when we um when we think back i think
a lot of tournaments just didn't have
online
live commentary yeah i would think it
might be young gustafsson
and simon williams and also i'm
wondering
how did your relationship develop and
how did
simon williams help you grow as a
streamer or become a streamer
um i mean simon
[Music]
i think first of all he helped me
because simon is one of my
my best friends um and it was so
nice to have him you know the the early
days he already had some experience and
i think rather than being i won't call
him a mentor but
i think he just made these early
streaming days so much
fun um i mean when i look back now they
look like something from the 90s
but we had you know it didn't look like
anything that is being put out there
today but we had so much fun
like our streams were so crazy and it
was just
uh sometimes i i almost feel nostalgic i
miss these
these early early crazy days but yeah
simon
uh was just you know he was my teammate
actually
the team that i was raising funds for so
he helped me really
quite a bit initially to to set up my
stream and then to join me on the
streams
and to actually even before i set up my
my own twitch channel i would sometimes
join his on his streams
him on his so he was a big a big
influence that's
that's for sure yeah simon's special
like
he's really special
uh the way he does his commentary is
just
different from the usual um okay go
ahead
yeah sorry no i was just gonna say it i
see the
the comment on youtube from chavi about
is the time to write
a book about my experiences and
interviews it's probably not a bad idea
that i
started writing them up before because
i'm so i have great memory for some
things but terrible memory for others
and
i mean that report question for example
it was embarrassing
uh like now the daisy panko interview is
so fresh in my memory but maybe in two
years you know
we did this again and you you asked me
yeah so that day when
magnus lost jessie franco year franken
so i should probably get on the case
sooner rather than later
so maybe it's time for fiona's
chess diary to start growing
but that's not so partly you know why i
do the the vlogs
um i think the vlogs are some of the
favorite things that i
uh that i do as a chess content creator
because
if you haven't seen them check them out
on my youtube
i think even for me sometimes now i look
at a vlog from a few years back and
there's things i've forgotten
or something so it's like a nice little
video diary
reminder of everything that goes on
behind the scenes at those
big events ever thought of making like a
vlog
compilation i know it takes a lot of
time but that could be an idea
like best off best off yes
yeah i mean that's the the thing is i i
have all these ideas but i just need to
actually get them done
and also i have to give a big shout out
to my
my editor anton squared me he used to do
so many funny photoshops but these days
he's so busy
he's so busy with work he still does
almost
everything you see on my channel be it
twitch or
youtube but he's become very busy
i've become quite busy but hopefully i
think it's a good idea and something
i'll keep in mind
yeah yeah yeah thank you for that
shout out and also so before i let you
go
what do you think what will be the
future where chess is going on streams
and in commentary in general
the thing is i mean lately i've seen a
few
i saw that for example hikaru was saying
he thinks that the future
of chess is really as in esports he
thinks
things that i haven't read the piece so
i don't want to quote him or anything
but basically i think he was saying
uh that the future if jess would be as a
as an esport
and even in vik i mean vik was such a
long time control some players who
always a bit complaining you know the
time control is too long the games can
last up to you know seven
and seven plus hours um
i really hope that classical chess
doesn't
go away i think there is absolutely
enough
space for you know chess as an esport
and classical chess and rapid and blitz
i think they all have their charms
and i think there's absolutely space for
them all to
to co-exist so i'm excited of course as
a streamer
to see where we're just online um
where it goes but i really do not
really do not want classical chess
to go anywhere but i think it's
anyone's guess i think for the next
couple of years surely there will not be
any
i hope i hope at least there will be no
dramatic changes but
if you ask me what will just be like in
in 10 years
i don't know but i'm curious curious to
find out
well that's good and i mean i'm hopeful
too i'd love to see both esports
and classical chess yeah for sure i
think
i think we need classic i think we even
need classical jazz for
for just as an esport to
to not necessarily to exist but i mean
classical chess is
the root of of everything and
and um yeah i think it shouldn't
i think it won't disappear and it
shouldn't and i do think that
uh honestly if we still have classical i
want to see a jordan fun forest first
world championship match yeah that would
be uh
that would be exciting i mean alireza of
course we haven't talked about him but
he's just
he's incredible um i think there is a
very good chance but i also always think
like
let's not let's not put too much
pressure
uh on the kid but he seems to be dealing
with it well because i remember a few
years ago everyone was like why ye
is all the rage next world champion and
now
i mean of course he's still a super
strong grandmaster but we don't hear
so much yeah of course i'm not saying
that we should put any pressure on
them but i feel that it'd be a good
match and i feel that
chess and they're kind of striving for
fun games and very exciting battles
it'd be just so nice to the world to see
that hey we're capable of this as well
yeah for sure i mean i'm curious to see
who's gonna
first of all when is this candidates
gonna conclude
uh and who's going to to qualify
um i hope i was there at the match in
london and it was so hard fought but it
was once though
i wish there had been a little bit more
more excitement i mean that's the
problem is that
both of them were just too strong and
too solid
um but yeah it would be nice to
to see um to see them exchange blows and
some exciting openings not just
not just the berlin yeah of course i
mean
all of these world championship matches
has their own intrigue
but you know new generation new intrigue
and i'm also hopeful probably in 2055
we'll have this candidates be done
hopefully dennis can i just address one
question from youtube because i don't
want it just uh jess was asking what it
was like working
uh with dania so just to address it so
that i don't it doesn't look like a
blanking
don't want to create any uh no i had
never worked with dania before so just
to answer it very briefly i had never
worked with dania before but
i enjoyed it tremendously um like i
think he's a
fantastic commentator and very nice guy
and
the whole experience was just very
pleasant i mean very easy going and
i hope we'll be reunited again in the
future
yeah dania is a great guy and again
fiona thank you so much
for being here and it was a pleasure
doing an interview with you
thank you so much dennis for for having
me and i was the pleasure is mine and
thank you so much to everyone who is
here and watching and
asking questions take care all right
thank you so much
for watching hope you enjoyed this
little talk with
fiona and with that i wish you a good
day or night wherever you are bye
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club
you